is america bipolar because every eight
years every four to eight years
the pendulum swings left to right
republican to democrat when's the last
time we've had consecutive democrats in
office or consecutive republicans in
office
to pat's point in 2016. you know hillary
didn't campaign in the midwest she took
it for granted trump came in he was all
over michigan all over ohio all over
iowa boom shocker alert he won the
election
2020 the blue wall held what as they say
and biden won the election but every
four to eight years
the pendulum swings i think it's because
hope springs eternal right someone else
said this so basically at any given
point after a certain number of years
that someone is in power and my
pocketbook is not doing well or whatever
it is that i'm upset about then the only
thing that triggers in my head why don't
i switch now and go with the other folks
maybe they have but that's change change
change the change agent right change
agent right so you know one of the
things that i found out in studying
decision making for 30 years is that we
are far from being sort of the hyper
rational creatures that we are otherwise
made out to be by classical economist
right classical economists have this
view called homo economicus homo
economicus means ultra rational you
apply these decision making procedures
you maximize utility whereas in reality
when you study human decision making
we're ultra non-rational enough right we
choose someone based on their height as
a politician well what does your height
have to do with your policies but you
simply look more presidential if you are
tall we haven't had a president under
like six foot and forever well by the
way whenever someone tells me hey why
don't you run for primer so i said sorry
i'm too short
it doesn't matter what's in here it the
fact that i'm i don't clock in at six
feet i'm out but it is a thing it is a
thing because people use these
peripheral candles if i'm tall that
means i'm dominant i'm to be trusted
right by the way ceos of companies are
taller than average right so the
napoleon bonaparte who was five foot
four is a very rare phenomenon most
elected people whether it be as a ceo as
a president are tall well what's the
story with nixon and jfk in that debate
if you listened on radio back in 64 or
whatever it was 61
if you listened on radio you thought
nixon won the debate exactly but if you
watched on tv because i think it was the
first televised debate right pat
jfk won the debate because he was more
polished he looked better
uh nixon was a little more like
disheveled kind of bearded five o'clock
shadow
um so
attractiveness does matter yep yep
exactly right so then that hat that
means joe biden is sexy as hell
he's he's hotter than leo and well he's
hotter than the orange man i guess
that's in the orange man yeah somebody
just commented saying whether you vote
rockefeller red or rockefeller blue
uh in a new world order the joke's on
you right i mean i don't know what that
obviously we know what the guy's trying
to insinuate but
and he rhymed too congratulations yes
medley butler good for you man total
rapper
uh but you know
you're saying all this stuff about where
it's at and what's happening but again
for me my confidence and peace of mind
of the future being bright is this new
movement of people who are able to
reason because if we go through the
sequencing on how i believe it happens
first there's a complainer
when there's a complainer the guy that
has the ability to reason he's got
better things to do than to argue with
the complainer okay
so then the complainer all of a sudden
creates momentum and he recruits eight
people 22 people 79 people 328 people
now he's got 1200 people
then the guy who's got the ability to
reason sitting there saying dude this
guy is creating some momentum
then the complainer starts converting
some of the people that the guy
who's has the ability to reason thought
they used to be reasonable okay then he
says i gotta now get involved then the
guy that has the ability to reason and
he's got a backbone gets involved and
start talkings and reasons through all
these issues then those people say yeah
i forgot i'm a guy that leans more
towards a reasonable side this
complainer you don't know what you're
talking about i flip
i think there's a big awakening of
people that can reason today and that's
what's happening and it's exciting
because most people that have the
ability to reason
and and they're driven by logic and they
can have an argument and kind of go
through and listen to both sides they're
typically so busy living their lives
they have no tolerance or time to go and
fight every single battle complainers
want to fight every battle those who
want to reason they don't have that kind
of time so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]